- I spend all day looking
at radicalization pathways
and the worst possible things
that can happen online.
- In terms of tracking, my
biggest concern this time
isn't Russian interference
in the election,
it's American mobilizations
at polling places,
threats of violence in terms of counting
or ballots or ballot boxes.
- Election security
officials and academics
say misinformation and disinformation
have never been more of a
threat to the U.S. election,
especially as coronavirus concerns
breed more confusion
around the voting process.
From misleading text messages
to false social media posts
shared by seemingly trusted sources,
bad actors are targeting many groups.
And often, the researchers
tracking the content
find themselves scrambling to keep up
with those spreading the false
or misleading information.
The researchers flag it to the platforms,
which also have their
own monitoring services.
What's at stake for the
2020 presidential election?
What's the worst that could happen
if misinformation runs rampant?
- What are we opening ourselves up to?
How are we normalizing the ingestion
of information in quick,
10-slide Instagram Stories?
- [Emily] Isabella Garcia-Camargo
is a cybersecurity researcher at Stanford
working on a coalition
focused on detecting
and mitigating misinformation
during the election.
- Even a year ago, a lot of people,
if you talked about QAnon,
nobody really knew what it was.
Since COVID, though, and
since the huge change
in kind of the information landscape
that came from that, the
movement has really grown
over the past couple of
months, and we're seeing it
pop up internationally even now.
- [Emily] The FBI has identified QAnon
as a potential domestic terrorism threat.
The far-right-wing,
loosely organized network
is one of the conspiracy theory groups
that has gained traction
since social distancing
forced many people to more
frequently interact online.
And it's not just online platforms.
Misinformation is spreading
more through text messages
or digital television ads,
especially as social media firms
crack down on such content.
- [Isabella] I think it's
important to recognize
that more and more young
people are getting their news
from TikTok, getting
their news from Instagram.
- People are isolated and they are trying
to figure out the world
from a digital feed.
Well, if that digital
feed is being manipulated
or bombarded with false information,
or being distorted through
paid advertisements,
it makes it very difficult for people
to understand what's going on.
- [Emily] Clint Watts is
a former FBI special agent
and a distinguished fellow
at the Foreign Policy Research Institute
studying social media influence.
Election security experts like Clint
say inaccurate voter
or polling information
could mean some miss their chance to vote.
While social media giants
like Facebook and Twitter
now have more stringent
policies against content
that could suppress
voters, security officials
are still worried about the damage done
before misinformation
is labeled or removed.
Conspiracies that claim mail-in ballots
aren't counted could dissuade some voters,
and questions about the
validity of election results
could threaten the future
of politics in America.
- [Isabella] It's less one candidate
will have an unfair advantage
or the other one will.
It's more like just generally
mistrust in the outcome
from the losing side
or from any side here.
If we start to erode
the trust that we have
in our democratic principles
and in our democratic system,
I think that that has very,
very long-term consequences.
- [Clint] I want people to
know that their vote counted,
and I want them to have
confidence in that.
- [Emily] Misinformation
has already spread
in this election cycle.
The legitimacy of mail-in ballots
has been questioned by
some, and in August,
a number of Florida voters received
a spoofed text message
alleging Rep. Byron Donalds
was dropping out of a congressional race.
Soon after, Donalds tweeted
that the text message
shared false information, and he,
in fact, was not dropping out.
- If you continue to pump disinformation
through the social media machine
and social media doesn't
regulate, to a degree,
what is actual verifiable
truth, lets deepfakes continue,
those sorts of things, well,
everyone loses in the end.
The companies fall into
a collapsing state,
the politicians can't advance policy,
and voters are just sorta
left hanging in the balance.
- Every single time
that you post something
to your Story, that you like a tweet,
your interactions are
like a vote in this space.
The most patriotic thing you can do
is to just think a little
bit before you like,
or you tweet, or you share things.